this I cannot believe this happened to
me so I thought I was done with her
she's banished for my show I know you
guys have a million comments don't bring
her back y'all
I promise you this crazy woman is not
coming back step one step two step two I
thought I was done with her I'm living
my life having a good time I am in the
studio and I'm going to let my dog out
my dog's like barking at me blah blah
blah you know you know how dogs are
so the dog I need to go let her out and
I'm taking her down the elevator and I
go into the lobby and guess who I see
guess who's there awaiting me crazy lady
the one that at the end of the show
refused to leave her name is Esther